quinze ans de réclusion criminelle alors
que l'avocat général n'en avait demandé
que 12
un verdict sévère qui a surpris tout le
monde même les parties civiles
on pensait pas quand même qu'il aurait
autant et moi personnellement je pense
que s'il avait présenté des excuses à la
fin qu'il aurait peut-être eu une
sanction un peu moins en vue avec cette
peine les jurés reconnaissent le
caractère criminel de l'acte d'yves
naudé en voulant mettre fin à sa vie il
a mis en danger celle de ses voisins
1/2 soulagement pour les victimes une
excuse s'arrêter chose nous pas d'
excuses et lors de l'audience un
témoignage qui a certainement emporté la
conviction des jurés
celui d'une de ses victimes une femme de
59 ans amputé d'une jambe après très
opération madame henri fait preuve d'une
émotion d'une sobriété exprimer ce qui
était sa vie d'aujourd'hui nous a donné
une extraordinaire leçon de vie la salle
d'audience et était vraiment retourner
complètement je pense que sa présence et
j'ai beaucoup insisté pour qu'elle soit
là elle ne voulait pas venir a fait
basculer finalement le l'issue du procès
la défense n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer à
l'issue de l'audience
yves naudet a dix jours pour faire appel
de la décision de la cour d'assises
il